I am here with Sir Charles Barkley and
we're gonna play a game that involves
some money I'll give you $15 what times
a tough one we have $15 and you were
going to make your dream NBA team for
this season I get to spend that much
what I gotta be economical though right
yes
$15 you ought to make it work okay don't
go $3 with LeBron he's worth five what
you can't be making up the runs after we
go so Phi it's $5 for LeBron then you'll
have 10 left
okay here's wisely I'm gonna take LeBron
okay that's my holy Sh sure one ha ha so
you're not going with your best friend
Oh my best friend give us victory ma
first of all he's way too high at $4 I'm
gonna take Kevin deny and already do you
think Kevin should have been a $5 player
yes okay she'd have been ahead of these
two guys these guys aren't as good as
Kevin yet I'm gonna take Russell okay
but you were having trouble picking here
who are you deciding between Russell and
him I want to know where his headset I
don't know if he wants to play in
Toronto he's just trying to get through
the year to go to the Lakers okay okay
so I got to be oh yeah you this is what
your you're down to I'm gonna go with
LaMarcus really yeah he's disgruntled he
lucky he planned in today's game if he
came to practice saying that stuff to us
at all days we've been fighting still
today and Jason Tatum you guys what in
the [ __ ] hey listen [ __ ] reporter the
army due me to do a go fund me for y'all
y'all let me I know times are tough big
if y'all need to go fund me page I need
[Music]